hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain an intriguing thriller and
horror fiction thailand series from girl
from nowhere season 1 called wonderwall
because it is an anthology series each
episode will present a different story
and you will be able to understand the
storyline without having to watch the
previous episodes
this episode has an unpredictable plot
twist watch it till the end to find out
the movie begins with a girl asking in
the back sound about what things that we
value the most as a human
is it success love or something else
a short-haired girl named bam is
currently a manager at her school's
football team
bam seems to have interest with one of
the players oh as she puts more
attention to him than other players
which makes them very jealous claiming
that she does not care about her duty as
a manager bam then asks oh to have ice
cream together but rejected because he
already has an appointment with her mom
moments later their coach vinai
approaches them and introduces a new
manager to the team
she is nano a beautiful girl who is
currently in the same grade as bam
bam's jealousy and hatred towards nano
grows because oh and other players show
more interest in nano because she is so
open cheerful and fair
here the backsound girl states that what
drives a human the most is hatred
the team plans to conduct a welcoming
party to nano oh who previously
mentioned that he had a schedule with
her mom suddenly would join the party
with nano this makes bam feel even
angrier towards nano
because nano is new to the team bam
becomes lazy as she only gives orders to
nano who does all the jobs alone seeing
bam not helping nano at all oh comes
towards her and offers help
he even blames bam for what she did
filled with hatred towards nano bam runs
to the bathroom as she spots random
writing on the wall she starts to write
hate speech on the same wall wishing
nano to have a smelly face
later on nano meets bam and sees her
writing on the wall suddenly she shows a
frightening smile
before sleeping she writes in her diary
about her encounter with nano claiming
that nano is her worst enemy and it was
satisfying because nano saw what she
wrote on the wall earlier the next day
at school bam suddenly smells something
disgusted as she passes by nano at first
she thinks that it's the smell of the
shirt
suddenly oh sees them and bam pretends
to help nano to show his kindness
towards the new co-manager
after helping she realizes that the
smell is not from the shirt as it is
just being washed
later on bam finally realizes that the
smell is actually from nano
at first everyone thinks that bam is the
one who makes the disgusting smell
then the boy realizes too that the smell
is from nano nano finally figures out
that the smell comes from her face she
then runs away from the group
bam discovers that what she wrote on the
wall earlier has become reality she then
writes on the wall hoping that oh would
fall in love with her later on coach
vinai asks bam about nano's performance
as the new manager
suddenly a ball is kicked towards bam
and oh manages to block the ball with
his body
but who's intention was actually to
protect the coach not bam
this means that what she wrote earlier
on the wall wouldn't come true
in addition bam's friend tang is teasing
her because she gets nosebleed just
because the boy she likes gets close to
her he also funnily says that he would
choose to protect a dog instead of her
because bam is not a good person
furious with the statement bam wildly
runs into the bathroom and writes tang
as a dog
suddenly school's situation becomes
chaotic as tang suddenly behaves like a
dog while playing football and has to be
taken to the hospital after this bam
realizes that everything she writes on
the wall will come true if it contains
hate speech to prove her silly thought
at lunch time bam sees nano is sitting
alone and writes nano as a dog on the
table but nothing happens
the next day bam is going to write
something on the wall when suddenly she
hears a group of girls is bullying
someone because of giving wrong homework
answers bam approaches the girl and
shares the wall secret to the bully girl
claiming that sometimes the writing
becomes reality but she gets ignored and
the girl walks away
later on the day the stink smell from
nano has disappeared as the boy
approaches her for a drink without any
complaint and tang is not acting like a
dog again
vam immediately rushes back to the
bathroom finding the writing has been
erased by the cleaner she tells the
cleaner not to clean the writing but
it's actually her job to do that the
cleaner then threatens her that she
would tell everything to the teacher
after school but cleaner tells about
bam's behavior to the coach and he urges
bam to apologize to the cleaner but she
refuses
instead she runs towards the bathroom
and writes something bad on the wall
again
a few moments later bam suddenly feels
frightened because the cleaner hangs
herself on the school hall
seeing what bam just wrote on the wall
the bullied girl approaches bam and
starts to believe her turns out that
previously bam wished the cleaner to
suffocate to death on the wall and it
came true
nano sadly asked spam why the cleaner
committed suicide as she is a very good
person and still has young children at
home
bam starts to feel horribly wrong so she
runs to the bathroom and wipes the
writing on the wall immediately after
leaving the room bam hears other
students conversation claiming that the
cleaner is suddenly alive like nothing
happened
afterwards bam accidentally sees nano
and oh flirting towards each other
suddenly nano is screaming and running
away with shame because her face is full
of pimples without a doubt the culprit
is bam who is having no regret of what
she just caused earlier
in the middle of the night bam wakes
from her sleep and unexpectedly finds
nano and the cleaner sitting in front of
her nano asks her why she killed the
innocent janitor and she keeps asking
the same question over and over again
until bam really wakes up from the
nightmare
while studying suddenly a female student
jumps out of the window
vam immediately runs towards the
bathroom to find out the culprit but she
meets the bullied girl claiming that the
wall is working it turns out that the
suicidal girl was the bully and the
bully girl is the one who wrote it after
that horrendous event a lot of students
begin to come to the bathroom and many
students start to behave strangely it
turns out that all of the students
already know about the wall magic and
the situation is now out of control
it even causes the principal's death
van confronts the bullied girl and
discovers that she is the one who
spreads information about the wonder
wall to everyone the girl claims that it
is satisfying to make bad people pay for
what they have done to other people
bam goes to the bathroom and sees a lot
of harsh words written on the wall one
of them is subjected to o
she immediately runs to oh and forces
him to stop playing again and go home
instead of helping suddenly bam causes
oh to fall into the ground and scream
badly
everyone panics and she spots a pen
then she questions one of those friends
who seems suspicious and asks him to
clean the writing immediately but he
does not answer and continues helping oh
feeling guilty bam runs towards the
bathroom and intends to wipe all the
writing on the wall but she finds words
that prevent anybody from wiping
everything because they will die if they
try to clean the wall
hopeless she then sits alone at the
football field regretting everything she
had caused
suddenly nano approaches her and asks
her what happened to her bam apologizes
and confesses everything to nano but
nano starts to laugh like a mad woman
nano claims that all bad things happen
were caused by bam and challenges bam to
admit her mistake and erase everything
on the wall if she dares bam confidently
accepts the challenge and quickly runs
towards the bathroom but nano shouts to
everyone that bam is going to erase all
the words on the wall
everybody starts to chase bam to prevent
her from erasing all the hate words
she tries so hard to wipe the words but
fails
so bam decides to write some words on
the wall and after a while all the
knocks on the door suddenly disappear
she then walks downstairs but can't find
anybody everyone vanishes except nana
she then desperately walks home and
discovers that herself is also
disappearing as she can't see the image
of her in the mirror at the end we
discover that the sentence she wrote on
the wall was i wish everyone would
disappear and she finally had it alone
in the world hopeless and desperate
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching